,
AN ANIMATEY ERLCE TO "THLEAD."KE
OVER.
JOHN DURHAM, THE SPECIAL
ATING WHHECTE  THESS IT NGS.
FOR YEARS DONALD TMP
INNED THEIR HOPES ON
CORRD MESTIGATION BY THE FORMEU.
HIALD
R REGARDING THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENTTTEMPTS TORFEN
AND MEME TWEETEDBLERS AND THE P
WOULD LEAD TO BOMBSHEL
WHO
. BOMBSHELL
DURHAM DID MINOR
VICTORY, TWO C
BUT ESO EN
FI OPENEDLY PRESSURED THE
ECTO RELEAHE
FINDINGS
IT HASPPED.
AND ITHTT PROD
SOME
REPU, IT IS SSTIO TH
FBA  T
BRING IN CNN SENIOR
EVWH E DIDISESPONDENT EVANZ.
>> THETOM FINN AM'S F
INVESTIGATION IS THAD VERY QUICD
A LD HAT THEY DID SO BY IGNORI
HAVE LED THEM TOP THAT
HE'S SAYING THAT THEMA HAD ONO W
ATIONS.
WHAT HE  TT TH
DECISION TO OPEN A  IF THE
TRUMP-RUSSIA TIES BAN 2016U  OF
HE SAYS THAT IT SEEMGH
KE,
CONFIRMA BIAS PLAYED ANT ROLE IE
TID NOT BEENUBJECTED T
TYPICAL EXACTINGS THAT
NOT THIV AE THE FSCOUNTED OWILL
CRITICISM HERE OE RMLEADERSHIP,,
McCABE, WHO WERE THE FBI
OVERSAW A LO THE
THAT THE REPORT ES POINTEDLI,
CHGE
BOS BRINGINGRG
THATTRUMP KEPT
E EXPECTEDTO
NO CHARGEABLE CRIMES AGAINST E I
PR TS  SOMETHING THAT THFO
INVESTIGATIO FAKE.
>>T'S ESTING.
OFFICE, THERE WERE TWO- ONE U.S.
DU'SE, BASED ON TH OF RT ISS AL
CROSS-FIRE HURN INTO TRUMP
JUE   RELATED INTELLIGHE
FAILED TO UPHOLD THEIR IOR
MIOF STRICDELITY TO
HE SAYS  QUOTE -G CERTAIN PENE
INTIMATELY IVED IN,  PON
INVESTIGATION INTO TRUMP.
ES
ATIONS,
'SING THESE WERE
MEET THE STANDARDS OF THJUST TH
FRANKLY KNOW A LOT OF THIS
ECTOR RAL, THE
A500-PAGE REPORTHT
T OF THESE FS THAT
DURHAM IS NOCONFIRMI,
FRANKLY.
REASONS WHY DURHAS BROUGHT ON
INSPECTOGEOF THE JUSTICEHE
OUND IR
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY WERE
O DO WASO TELLS A
LOT T WHAT INTELLIGENCE MMUNITY.
THEY DIDN'T FINMUCH THEREN THEY
HAD THAT THERE WAS AF
PEOPLE FROM FBI ANOME
LOOK, THERS T IN HERE THSHI HAV
QUF THSOMEOR
CHANGES THAT THEY  TY'
MA TO MAKE SURE LI
E E END OF TOM L WHAT WE
FOUR-YEAR IN
DOESN'T TELL US  OF A LOT
ATE  AE
YEARS AGNSK AT MAN E THINGS AND
17-- OUBLINFIID THE
FBI NEEDED TO FIX,
THING.
RA C, WH
SPOKMA CDIRECTOR FOR MARWARNERS
THLECT COMMITTN
S --EX
THAT THE SENATE INTELLIGENCE3 1T
D INTERVWI HEDS OF
WITNESSES, THI
ANLU THE FBI
CONCERN IN 2016. THEEE
COMMITTEE AT THE TIMS LEPUBLICS.
AGAIN, BOT THESE TRUE .LE THAT
HOULD HAVE IS ALSO POSE THAT SOA
BEEN.
>> R THE THINGS YOU COMEY WITH
IT, REMEMBER THAT  2019 DURHAM
CAME OUT WITH  HIGHL
UNUSUAL STATEMENT INE
FI GENERALSAGR
WHH  W
TICE
DEPARTI TO
INATE THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
HE SH  TODT, DURHAM SAYS
E SEESN FOR THI
TO AT LEASTAKE AK AT SOME
OF TTIAL TS THAT LED TO
WHS-FIRE
HURRICANE.HE SAID THE FBHAD
INVESTIG AARESN'T  ASON FOR A F
INVESTIGATION ACCORDING TO THI
REPORT.
JAKE, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT D I
DETE SPYING., THER THA
A CONFIDENTIAL HUMCESP
WAS TASKED WITG TO A CLINN
T THATA IN FE FBGOTTEN
INFORMATIOATODY WA
SAYING THAT PERH
GOVERNMENT MIGHTE EXPECTING
SOME FAVORS FROM A FUTURE
N PRESIDENCY.
SO THERE YOU HAV
I WANG
CLINTON CAMPAIGNAS THE FBI THE
CHRISTOPHER WRFB
OUT
HAENU E FBI WANTS TOOUT, JAKE, E
WHO WERE I
ARE IN FOR VERY IS THIS REPORTE
FROM THE F
>> AND THE CURRETOAPPOINTED BY
TRUMP, NOTAS STO
HIM  C C
LES BRIN ELIE HONIG AND
HERE IT IS, ALL 300- PAGES,
DURHAM H FOUT TH
SHOULD NEVER HAV A
FULLO
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN TRUMP,
ASSOCIATES IN HIS CAMPAIGN ANDN
THAT CUS AORGONE CONCLUSIO
THE START.
LET'S REMEMBN DURHAM MEO
T MIDDLOF 2019 WHENR LUD HI
INVESTIGATION, DONALD TRUMP WAS
TAKING TO TWITTERLY ALVESTIGE A.
REALMOMED JOHN DURHAM TOINVESTID
IN DECEMBEOF 2019, DOJ'S O
INSPECTOR GENERAL CAME OUT WH
MIHERE WND TO OPENN
INVESTIGATION.RIGHT AWAY JDUE OU